[Music]
Vatican anthem
[Music]
and once again the fanfare
exceeding the Italian anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
here on the the central entrance to the
Basilica we see the staircase
dear brothers and sisters in Rome
throughout the world happy Christmas
foreign
of confidence and hope together with the
gift of Peace proclaimed by the angels
to the Shepherds of Bethlehem glory to
God in the highest heaven and on Earth
peace to those whom he favors
[Music]
foreign
on this festive day we turn our gaze to
Bethlehem the Lord comes to the world in
a stable and is laid in a Manger for
Animals since his parents could find no
room in the Inn even though the time had
come for Mary to give birth he comes
Among Us in silence and in the dark of
night because the word of God needs no
Spotlight or loud human voices he is
himself the word that gives life its
meaning the light that brightens our
path the True Light which enlightens
everyone the gospel tells us has come
into the world
Jesus is born in our midst he is God
With Us
it comes to accompany our daily lives to
share with us in all things our Joys and
Sorrows our hopes and fears
he comes as a helpless child
the door of our heart to find warmth and
shelter
like the Shepherds of Bethlehem
surrounded by light may we set out to
see the sign that God has given us
may we overcome our spiritual drowsiness
and the shallow holiday glitter that
makes us forget the one whose birth we
are celebrating
let us leave behind the Hue and din that
deadens our hearts makes us spend more
time in preparing decorations and Gifts
than in contemplating that great event
the Son of God born for us
brothers and sisters let us turn our
eyes to Bethlehem and listen to the
first faint crime she's of the Prince of
Peace yes for truly Jesus is
the peace that the world cannot give
the peace that God the father has
bestowed on Humanity by sending his son
into the world
summed up the message of this day and a
concise Latin phrase
[Music]
is the birth of peace
Jesus Christ is also the way of Peace
by his Incarnation passion death and
Resurrection has opened the way that
leads from a World closed in on itself
and oppressed by the Dark Shadows of
enmity and War to a world that is open
and free to live in fraternity and peace
brothers and sisters let us follow that
yeah in order to do so to be able to
walk behind Jesus we must divest
ourselves of the burdens that weigh us
down and block our way and what are
these burdens
what is that dead weight
the same negative forces that prevented
King Herod and his court from
acknowledging and welcoming the birth of
Jesus
falsehood
these forces hold us back from going to
Bethlehem they exclude us from the grace
of Christmas and they block the entrance
to the path of Peace indeed we must
acknowledge with sorrow that even as the
Prince of Peace is given to us I see
Winds of War
continue to Buffet Humanity
if we want it to be Christmas the birth
of Jesus and of peace let us look to
Bethlehem and contemplate the face of
the child who is born for us and in that
small and innocent face let us see the
faces of all those children everywhere
in the world who long for peace
let our eyes be filled with the faces of
our Ukrainian brothers and sisters who
are living this Christmas in the dark
may the Lord Inspire us to offer
concrete gestures of solidarity to
assist all those who are suffering and
may He Enlighten the minds of those who
have the power to silence the Thunder of
weapons and put an immediate end to this
senseless World
tragically we prefer to heed other
councils dictated by worldly ways of
thinking yet who is listening to the
voice of the child
our time is experiencing a grave Famine
of peace also in other regions and other
theaters of this third world war let us
think of Syria still scarred by a
conflict that has receded into the
background but has not ended let us
think two of the Holy land where in
recent months violence and
confrontations have increased bringing
death and injury in their way let us
beseech the land that there and the land
that witnessed his birth
dialogue and efforts to build Mutual
trust between Israelis and Palestinians
May resume
may the Child Jesus sustain the
Christian communities living in the
Middle East so that each of those
countries can experience the beauty of
fraternal coexistence between
individuals of different faiths
May the Christ child help Lebanon in
particular so that it can finally
Rebound with the help of the
International Community and with the
strength born of fraternal a fraternity
and solidarity
May the Light of Christ illume in the
region of this
where peaceful coexistence between
peoples and traditions is disrupted by
conflict and acts of violence May that
light lead to a lasting truth in Yemen
and to reconciliation in Myanmar and
Iran and an end to all Bloodshed
may it Inspire the political authorities
and all people of Goodwill in the
Americas to attempt to calm the
political and social tensions
experienced by various countries and I
think in particular
of the people of Haiti
who have been suffering for a long time
and this
as we sit around a well-spread table may
we not avert our gaze from Bethlehem a
town whose name means House of Bread
and let us think of all those especially
children
who go hungry while huge amounts of Food
daily go to waste and resources are
being spent on weapons
the war in Ukraine has further
aggravated this situation putting entire
peoples at risk of famine especially in
Afghanistan and in the countries of the
Horn of Africa we know
that every war causes hunger
and food is exploited as a weapon
hindering its distribution to people who
are already suffering
on this day let us learn from The Prince
of Peace
with those who hold political
responsibilities that they commit
themselves to make food solely an
instrument of peace
and as we enjoy gathering with our loved
ones let us think of those families who
are experiencing greater hardship and
notice that in this time of economic
crisis are struggling
because of unemployment and to lack the
nest the basic necessities
dear brothers and sisters
Jesus the true light comes into a world
sick with indifference a world that does
not welcome him and indifference that
does not welcome him rather rejects him
as it does with many
foreigners or ignores him as we all too
often do with the poor
let us not forget today the many
displaced persons and refugees who knock
at our doors in search of some comfort
warmth in food
let's not forget the marginalized the
people who are who live alone the
orphans and the elderly who risk being
set aside
the prisoners whom we regard solely for
their mistakes
and not that they are a fellow human
beings
brothers and sisters
Bethlehem shows us the Simplicity of God
who reveals himself not to the wise and
the intelligent but to the little ones
to those with a pure and open heart
like the Shepherds let us too sit out
and haste and allow ourselves to be
amazed by the unthinkable event of God
who becomes man for our Salvation okay
the source of all good makes himself
poor asking us
the alms of our own poor Humanity let us
allow ourselves to be deeply moved by
the love of God and let us follow Jesus
who stripped himself of his glory in
order to that he could share in our
fullness Merry Christmas
to everyone
let's see
[Applause]
and now we proceed with the
announcing of this Indulgence which
is granted not only to those here in
Saint Peter's square but also those who
are unable to be physically present but
who devoutly follow it through
television radio or Internet
first the Angelus yes
[Music]
[Music]
it is
foreign
[Music]
we prepare ourselves to receive uh
disciplinary Indulgence
as we know the Indulgence in order to
for us to receive it also requires the
reception of sacramental confession and
communion and a prayer foreign
[Music]
all the saints
May almighty God have mercy on you and
forgive all your sins and may Jesus
Christ bring you to life Everlasting
absolutions
Absolution and the remission of all your
sins a season of True and fruitful
Penance a well-disposed heart amendment
of Life the grace and comfort of the
Holy Spirit and final perseverance and
good works
amen
ities
but this is
something they said amen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
let me see Cardinal cimorero there in
the background
our Holy Father looking down with the
exchange taking place between
the
battalions of the pontifical swissgard
and the Italian Armed Forces
[Applause]
once again we'll hear the the Fanfare
followed by the respective anthems
foreign
[Music]
and now we'll hear the Fanfare followed
by the papal anthem
created in 1949 by order of Pius XII
[Music]
the holy father's still looking down
below
orders being given to the pontifical
Swiss guard here
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s have now exchanged anthems the
pontifical Swiss guard now playing the
Italian Anthem and prior to that the
Italian Armed Forces playing the
pontifical anthem
[Applause]
The pontifical Anthem not to be
misunderstood as a national anthem
because the the words and music
speak to the heart of many throughout
the world who see in Rome the Sea of
Peter the commanders now exchanging
sides and
thank you
reviewing the the troops of the other
side our Holy Father now waving from the
loja to all of those who have gathered
below
then our Holy Father now making his way
back into the aula de la benedicione
and with this images we know and this
live broadcast of the Christmas day or
be it Orbee message and blessing I
invite you to visit the Vatican news web
portal Facebook Instagram Twitter and
YouTube accounts for coverage of today's
or be at Orbee another Vatican and world
news we will be back tomorrow from Saint
Peter's Square the feast of Saint
Stephen for the Angelus message from
Pope Francis and the recitation of that
traditional prayer beginning just before
noon Rome time on behalf of attic and
media I'd like to thank all of our Media
Partners Euro